say whoa
time out you're you're making a five
million dollar feature but it's not
finance and and you don't have
distribution so how are you making the
five million dollar feature again like
does having a higher budget let's say
over 500 000 guarantee that your movie
is probably going to be of a higher
caliber story wise
if you're a good producer slash director
like a good producer director team who
knows how to
deploy their resources you know very
very effectively then
i would say the more you have to spend
the better quality your movie is likely
going to be
as long as you're not wasting it like if
you're putting it on screen you know
like if you let's say i'll give you an
example okay let's say you have a 500
000 movie right
and then you get an extra 50 000
if you go and hire like a fancy caterer
who's going to do the meals yeah will
your crew and cast feel a little bit
better
sure they will but will it make your
movie better probably not but if you
spend that fifty thousand dollars
potentially on one scene where it's a
big production you know a bigger
location with more extras or something
like that then it'll make your movie
better so that's what i mean by
deploying the resources effectively
so if you're
you always have to be careful with your
resources no matter what you have so
people think at 250 i have to be more
careful than at 500 no you have to be
careful of both levels and at 750 just
deploy them as best you can so that you
put most of it on screen so that your
movie looks better so obviously the more
you have to spend if you're deploying it
wisely you have a better chance at
making a
higher quality looking movie you know
potentially more production value now
obviously it's going to always end up
there's there's elements that doesn't
matter how much you spend
acting
all right now you could say the more i
spend on actors the better actors i'm
going to get i don't personally believe
that i believe that there's good actors
at every
price range
and hopefully you get good performances
out of them all right so you could say
you know i'll get a better
cinematographer if i spend more money
you'll definitely get a more experienced
cinematographer because you know they
have that's why they're charging more
because they've done more and you know
chances are it's more predictable but it
doesn't mean a brand new cinematographer
can't you know shoot a great movie i
mean there's young upcoming people who
are really talented who just need a
break
so hopefully you get one of those you
know and directors and all this kind of
stuff um hopefully it all gels and
and
so i that's where you the magic can
happen at low budgets where everything
gels and you just get great performances
great directing
sometimes you know experience does
matter and you don't make the rookie
errors because you've done it before
and that's why spending more money on
people who know what they're doing is a
little bit more predictable
but it doesn't mean that people who
haven't done it before can't do it well
but you know to get back to your
question yeah if you had an extra 250
and you put most of it on screen
your movie's gonna look better it's just
gonna look bigger and and you know
hopefully like when i say on screen
you're using more extras your costumes
are better your production value is
better by the way if if the story's bad
the acting's bad you could spend 5
million and still come up with a bad
movie i mean you know a bad movie is
going to be a bad movie
um so
it does start with a decent story a
decent vision from the director and good
performances and then the rest is just
capturing it properly you know focus
sounds the shots you choose that kind of
stuff
earlier you said the audience doesn't
care what you paid for your movie i know
film festival audiences might care
though because they just want to know
what was your budget range and how can i
emulate what you did kind of everybody
lies i go to tons of festivals i sit in
these screenings and they say well how
much was your budget oh i'm going to
tell you the truth and then they they
usually triple it or quadruple it nobody
wants to say they made a 10 000 movie
because it feels too small right
so how do you know what's real unless
you've done the accounting for it
um i've been there done that i know what
things cost i know you know now when a
filmmaker says to me hey i didn't pay
anybody then i say great um you know
you're lucky that you got people to work
for free
i don't do the movies that way i believe
they should get paid but i'm not saying
it's wrong you know sometimes people say
oh i spent five years making my movie
because i just shot on weekends or this
or that type of thing i say okay fine
but you know i'll gain it's not my
business model i'd rather shoot in 20
days consecutively get it done release
it do the next thing so everyone's got a
sort of a different business model and a
different vision of what that could be
but when i say people don't care about
how much they spend people like to
discuss it they like to throw numbers
around they like to because you know
they want a point of reference for
themselves to see you know can i make a
movie how much does it really cost so
there are people who are curious
especially at festivals you know who
want to sort of know because maybe
they're thinking of making their own
movies so they're doing that as a point
of reference
um but
if you've watched a movie
and you've left the theater and you said
wow that's a great movie and then
somebody said to you oh that costs fifty
thousand or five million
you'd be way more impressed if it was
fifty thousand wouldn't it be way more
because all of a sudden this great movie
this epic movie was made for fifty
thousand dollars and the surprise would
be on the low end as opposed to the high
end so i always joke and i say if i were
to ever win an academy award in my
speech i'm gonna say what the actual
budget was because it's gonna be so much
lower than what anybody expected it to
be you know because everybody expects if
it's a good movie that it has to cost
all
so much money and by the way
here's the other problem with the
narrative that indie filming everybody
throws around hollywood style numbers oh
i'm making you know i told you before i
get phone calls i'm making a five
million dollar feature
and uh and it's all ready but i just
need you know finance and distribution
i say whoa time out you're you're making
a five million dollar feature but it's
not finance and you don't have
distribution so how are you making the 5
million feature again like
in your mind you're making a 5 million
dollar feature but in reality what
you're probably going to spend is 50 000
i mean that's what's really going to
happen if you want this feature made
unless you are connected to some really
high net worth individuals who are
prepared to make big donations to you
so everybody still throws around the big
numbers especially in the hollywood
circles and everybody wants to pretend
holly and at festivals you know it's
hollywood talk right which is you know
well 2.5 i made my movie for you know
3.2 and blah blah blah and it's like
all right whatever
doesn't look like you did so you know
it's different strokes for different
folks
what does it cost to get bankable stars
in your movie so bankable stories you
mean a-list talent basically people who
can
who people say who's in it and when you
say the name they say oh i know that
person that's a bankable star all right
so that's what i call bankable because
there are sort of secondary bankable
words oh i've heard of that person as
opposed to oh
you know when someone goes to see a
movie in the theater the first question
they asked is who's in it and you know
that's why a-list actors make so much
money because people say oh if they're
in it i'll go see the movie right they
don't say what's the movie about they
generally say who's in it even for
animated films they say that's the crazy
part like i mean you're talking voice a
talent you know
so what does it cost um it's
flexible
but a-list talent cost more than
it then indie film producers can afford
and the other thing is that chances are
a-list talent doesn't want to do indie
films unless it's their story or they're
personally connected and they want to
direct and the reason is is because
an a-list
actor does not want to be associated
with a c-list film like the production
value is too low and it's going to taint
their reputation
um i say unless it's their story and
they're or they're very connected to the
filmmaker or whatever and they want to
help share that vision
so i'm gonna say that you know a-list
talent you know is in the
seven-figure range like you know the
million-dollar plus range um b
b or say a minus list or b plus you know
is going to be high six figures
um and you know when you're making a
movie for a half a million dollars or
even a million dollars
and you want an a-list actor then your
budget just doubled you're gonna have a
two million dollar movie now a lot of
people will say i mean all the
distributors who are watching this will
say it's worth it
because that's what's going to sell the
movie
and they're right it is worth it
if you know for sure you got a sale on
the movie see if you go that route and
you don't get your sale you've just
doubled your budget you've taken a huge
risk and maybe it's not going to work
but some people say it's a better risk
to put an a-list actor in and spend that
money it's less of a risk than it is to
not have that a lot of international
distributors will say to you don't even
bother making a movie unless you have
recognizable bankable talent
which i don't
totally disagree with
but you know the genre i work in family
i don't really use any recognizable
talent
because i think it's more about the
story than it is about the actor now it
recognizable talent wouldn't hurt but i
don't think the numbers would justify in
terms of the selling side the cost of
the actor now there's some people that
use previous a-list actors who maybe now
have become
you know i don't know what their rating
would be but then there's a draw in that
too that someone that had been out of
the limelight for a while hadn't been
working for whatever the reason is and
now has made a comeback and they may be
totally different persona wise
appearance wise than they once were and
then that's probably a draw as well very
very big draw that's very very common
you know i call them a minus or b plus
list actors people who are not you know
in the limelight you know they're not
the top 50 or whatever in hollywood but
they're still they've done they've been
there done that and are very
recognizable
very good for international sales
because people still recognize their
face or their name so that's much more
common and and it is bankable also but
it's not cheap
you know a b-list actor could be
fifty thousand dollars a day
not uncommon to see that at all and
they're worth it you know first of all
they're good actors right so you pretty
well can depend on them giving a good
performance usually
um and yeah they have that that sale
ability or what you call the bankability
um and
you don't know for sure how bankable it
is um but you're pretty certain it's
better to have them not than not to have
them but it's just it's just a finance
equation right so like if you were to
say to me why don't you put you know
like two b-list actors into lead roles
in your movie and i'm going to say
because it'll double the you know be
half a million dollars in in that fee
and i don't think i'm gonna i think i'll
only
increase my sales by say 350 000. so i'm
doing some calculations beforehand and
saying it's not
feasible for me to do that but if i did
it the other way and said you know by
putting a 500 000 actor in i could get
you know a million dollars of extra
sales of course i would do it